what would television be without Netflix
wait stop it's too unbearable to even
imagine Netflix's introduction of show
after awesome show in 2016
left TV watchers hardly able to catch
their breaths and it doesn't look like
Netflix is going to slow down in 2017
with a miles long list of series to
binge watch in the coming months
here are the Netflix shows that will
blow everyone away in 2017 frontier
frontier premiered on Discovery Channel
Canada in November 2016 to some
seriously solid ratings and made the
move to Netflix mid January 2017 giving
TV lovers the perfect excuse to watch
all six episodes in a single sitting
the Canadian American period drama
chronicles a band of men battling to
reclaim ownership and to seize control
of the fur trade in 18th century North
America and there's one familiar face
that may very well have fans cheering
Game of Thrones Jason Momoa better known
as the beloved Khal Drogo is back on the
not-so big-screen frontier is a
multi-faceted weaves through cultural
relations and the savagery of America in
his adolescence not only does the show
promise a healthy portion of violence
insane action sequences and sharp
dialogue but it also presents a
historical glimpse into the
pre-industrial times in North America
education and entertainment that's a
win-win santa clarita diet Sheila and
Joel Hammond may seem like a normal
suburban pair of real estate agents but
their fridge tells another story if you
love zombie stories but you're looking
for a leaf from the constant misery of
The Walking Dead be sure to check out
the comedy horror series Santa Clarita
diet which premiered on Netflix in early
February starring Drew Barrymore and
Timothy Olyphant as a California couple
Santa Clarita Diet follows Sheila's
radical transformation who may end up
biting off more than she can chew
literally mind hunter based on the book
of the same name this Netflix series
roles time back to 1979 where the
Jonathan Groff and Holt Macallan a
starring as FBI behavioral science unit
special agents who take on the daunting
task of conducting interviews with
currently imprisoned criminals but not
just any criminals these two said I - I
was serial killers with Charlize Theron
and David Fincher in mind hunters
executive producer seats brace yourself
for a drama that will lead
sleeping with the lights on Marvel's
Iron Fist superhero films series and
spin-offs are huge hits with audiences
worldwide recently Netflix rolled out a
triple threat of comic crime-fighting
shows and Marvel's Jessica Jones Luke
Cage and daredevil in 2017 Netflix is
adding yet another superhero show to its
table Marvel's iron fist
the fourth Marvel series to find his
home on Netflix iron fist stars Finn
Jones in the title role billionaire
Buddhist monk Danny Rand has returned to
his home city of New York after spending
years as a recluse honing his
unparalleled martial arts prowess danny
summons a power of you guessed it the
iron fist as he takes down new york's
most corrupt villains with a deadly
punch the series hits Netflix in full on
March 17 2017 and helps set the stage
for Marvel's the defenders vote official
release date has yet to be announced
Marvel's the defenders will definitely
be buzzed about right up until it
reaches screens and likely well beyond
the 8th episode miniseries brings
together all of those heroes audiences
know and love from their standalone
shows Kristen retro as Jessica Jones
Mike Colter as Luke Cage Charlie Cox as
daredevil and the guy we just talked
about Finn John's as iron fist also
joining the superhero studded character
ensemble our elektra natchios vigilante
nurse Claire temple and the
sophisticated and sinister villain
Alexandra the group takes on all the bad
guys in mid 2017
Bill Nye saves the world if he were
American and in school during the 90s
and early noughts you likely remember
the notoriously catchy theme song to the
live-action educational science show
Bill Nye the Science Guy the famed
science educator and the mechanical
engineer who taught viewers about cells
photosynthesis and the mysteries of the
night sky is back this time for his very
own talk show bill Nyes saves the world
will go beyond the realm of just science
extending into politics fiscal and
social trends and pop-culture phenomena
across the globe with a lots of
interesting ground to cover
Michael's in backup with a few special
field correspondents so audiences can
learn about the wonders of the world and
its people places and things as mr. Nye
debunks myths and refutes anti science
claims in spring 2017 wet hot American
summer ten years later despite being a
box office
mm and ones wet hot American summer was
a cult favorite comedy with a talented
cast that included Molly Shannon Paul
Rudd Elizabeth Banks Michael Ian Black
Bradley Cooper and Amy Poehler just to
name a few nearly a decade and a half
later fans still wanted more so Netflix
released an eight-episode prequel series
in the summer of 2015 which was
ridiculous in the best way possible all
the actors reprise their roles only to
play even younger versions of their
beloved characters next comes wet hot
American summer ten years later in which
the cast collaborates once again
this time at a more age-appropriate
level the sequel series is set in 1991
and it's inspired by some classic 80s
comedies friends from college
starring one of the funniest funny men
out there keegan-michael key
alongside How I Met Your mother's cobie
smulders friends from colleges premise
is one that becomes reality for almost
everyone
you and your once rowdy college friends
are officially middle-aged and you're
coping with it in some pretty
interesting ways
[Applause]
dark we all know how captivated
audiences were in the summer of 2015
when making a murderer made its Netflix
debut subsequently taking the TV
watching world by storm with its winding
tale of drama behind the scenes footage
and shocking secrets
it seems history will repeat itself with
dark a family drama that tracks the
trauma and a devastation that Rock a
small German town following the
mysterious disappearance of two children
while it's a work of fiction
it seems the show is guaranteed to
incite goosebumps and grim realizations
in his audience throughout its 10
episode first season big mouth it's not
all going to be gritty thrillers and
action filled shows coming to Netflix in
2017 this tongue-in-cheek
slightly risky animated comedy from Nick
Kroll and Andrew Goldberg has been a
long time coming as Kroll put it in a
Netflix press release Andrew and I have
been best friends since first grade so
this show is over 30 years in the making
not only does Kroll service creator he's
also voiced in one of the main
characters himself Galvez Sophia Amoruso
declaimed autobiography girl boss is
getting the Netflix adaptation treatment
in a series centered around the clothing
brand entrepreneurs rise to success
starting off humbly selling vintage
threads on eBay a Moroso shot into
international stardom after setting up
the wildly popular and wickedly trendy
fashion brand turned Empire Nasty Gal
and this comedy series will explore her
story with its 13 episode debut in April
as arc film goers saw Jason Bateman play
a slightly more sinister character than
his usual goofball charmer in joel
edgerton 2015 thriller the gift now
Bateman settling into another sordid
Roldan Netflix's upcoming series Ozark
Bateman stars as a financial planner who
packs up his life in the Chicago suburbs
and heads to a home near the lake of the
ozarks in Missouri but his intentions
aren't so squeaky clean stranger things
- following up on their breakout first
season the duffer brothers were returned
to Hawkins Indiana for some monstrous
throwback firm with stranger things -
which debuts on Halloween the second
season of stranger things will pick up a
year after the first season left off
after its crew of kill adventurers
defeated the devil Gorga
both lost contact with their friend
11:00 in the process if the Super Bowl
previews for stranger things - are any
indication the intensity of the show's
second season is going to be Full Tilt
and fans will be tempted to ditch out on
the usual trick or treat routine for an
evening spent watching every episode of
the new season count on stranger things
- to be even well stranger than the
first season with a storm coming along
to bring some new otherworldly baddies
into the small town fold dear white
people 2014 saw the indie film dear
white people bring racial tensions and a
bright white community to the surface
and handled it with a ton of smarts and
satire piggybacking on the original film
comes a television adaptation of the
same name with a group of Ivy League
students of color navigating their
nearly all-white Winchester University
campus to discover not only is the lack
of diversity shocking but so is the
number of misinformed or just plain
biased students El Chapo Netflix seems
to have kept its eye on the foreign
entertainment Rome heading into 2017
as the company has teamed up of
spanish-language broadcast network
Univision for his upcoming drama series
centered around real-life drug lord and
wanted criminal
Joaquin archibald a Guzman Liara more
commonly known by his nickname el chapo
the drama series based on the trials and
insane illegal endeavors of Guzman's
life will hit any mass audiences before
it reaches Netflix subscribers but when
it does it promises to deliver big-time
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know your love to
[Music]